WIL WILLIS: Joshua,
Jesse, congratulations.
You guys have landed
in the final round
of this competition.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
weapon from history.
That weapon is a Lochaber ax.
Good luck.
We'll see you in four days.
We're back at my home
forge in Liverpool,
and I'm ready to get
started on the Lochaber ax.
Finishing something that's
this big that I've never
done before in such a
short amount of time
is a huge challenge.
Forging everything by
hand has its advantages
and disadvantages.
The advantage is
that you learn how
to move steel pretty quickly.
But the disadvantage
is that it takes
its toll on you physically.
I'll be forced to
width today, and I'll
be forced to length today.
I'm going to make the
best blade I can make,
and hopefully it's a $10,000 ax.
I have four days
instead of the five days,
so that means there's no time
to waste in this contest.
There's five pieces
to this entire build,
so getting everything to
mesh together perfectly,
that's going to be
the biggest challenge.
I know that when we
get to the testing
that I have to make sure that
this thing is as sturdy and as
stout as possible,
because they are
going to beat the ever-loving
crap out of this thing.
This is a war machine,
so I want to make sure
that it is a lightweight blade.
If the blade is
too heavy, I mean,
that could be the
difference between winning
and losing this competition.
JOSHUA: Today I'm going
to profile the blade
and get the bevel on it.
I also want to get
that hook attached
today, too, so it's
going to be a busy day.
I forged out my hook.
And as I'm grinding the hook,
there's a crack in my hook,
right down the middle.
I don't want to fucking have to
start goddamn shit over again.
I can't afford to
lose any time today.
And I need to do this again.
Ugh, I don't have time
to do things twice.
I'm running a
little behind today,
so I don't have time to
fuck with it too much.
I got to kick it up a notch.
JESSE: Day four, I got a lot
of handwork that I have to do.
There's a lot of hand sanding,
polishing, ruling, so a lot
of small tedious work today.
Eight and a half pounds.
I'm about two and a
half pounds over what I
actually wanted to have there.
It's little bit more
difficult to swing
and everything like that.
And there's a couple of little
tabs that I can cut off.
The nuts, and the bolts, and
everything like that, that's
coming out for rivets.
I shaved off a
good pound, and it
definitely feels much lighter.
I hope that the weight
isn't the determining factor
when it comes down to
the final judgment.
This challenge was
absolutely a wrecking ball,
but I love this blade.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, bladesmiths.
This is the kill test.
Now, to find out how
lethal your weapons are,
I will take your Lochabers
and deliver killing
blows on this pig carcass.
Joshua, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yeah, let's do it.
I don't mind going first,
other than the fact
that I might pass out
because of anticipation.
But I'm ready to see
this thing get to work.
[rock music]
[blow impacts]
DOUG MARCAIDA:
All right, Joshua.
First up, your blade,
it's a pork chopper.
On its thrust, did you
see the wound channel?
It creates such
a big, deep gash.
It's fun to wield.
It's sharp.
And most importantly,
it will kill.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, Jesse.
Your turn.
Are you ready?
Absolutely.
Let's do it.
I'm really anxious
about this test.
It's a little bit heavy.
I'm hoping that that's not going
to be a determining factor.
I don't know how
this is going to go.
[rock music]
[blow impacts]
First up, your
blade has the weight
that every chop into
something, want to keep going.
It wants to keep going, and
going, and going to where
it pretty much took me with it.
Good chops, good cuts.
And more importantly,
it will kill.
Thank you.
All right.
Up next, the strength test.
Dave.
To test the strength
and overall construction
of your weapons, I'll
be hooking the shield,
pulling it into place, and then
attacking it with the blade.
All right, Josh,
you're up first.
Are you ready?
Oh yeah.
[rock music]
[blow impacts]
So first off, you took a
little bit of deformation
here, pretty much where that
edge caught some of the studs
on that shield.
But it's still sharp.
It's really a nicely built
piece, got a good look to it.
It's easy to wield.
Everything's still solid.
Strong ax-- nicely done.
- Thank you.
- All right, Jesse.
Your turn.
Are you ready?
Absolutely.
[rock music]
[blow impacts]
All right, Jesse.
You can see on your
blade here where you've
taken a pretty good roll here.
And this is sort of
a roll and a chip.
But everywhere else on
this blade is still sharp.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
DAVID BAKER: All
right, gentlemen.
Next up, the sharpness test.
And for that, I'll
give you to Doug.
This is the sugar-cane slice.
Now, to find out how
sharp your weapons are,
I will take your
weapons and deliver cuts
across these sugar-cane bundles.
Joshua, you're up first.
Ready for this?
- Let's do it, man.
- Let's do it.
[suspenseful music]
[blow impacts]
DOUG MARCAIDA:
All right, Joshua.
You contoured this shaft here
so that when you hold onto it,
you can really tell
where the edge is.
I really like that.
Overall, sir, your
weapon is sharp.
It cuts all the way
through cleanly.
It will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Jesse.
Your turn.
Are you ready?
You betcha.
It feels like I might be
kind of at a setback right
now just because my edge seemed
like it took more damage.
It can come down to
the finest details.
[suspenseful music]
[blow impacts]
Nice.
All right, Jesse.
The blade is heavy.
It cuts, but also you can
feel the weight behind it
crush the rest of it.
Overall, sir, for this
test, it will cut.
Thank you.
JOSHUA: Who's going
to win this challenge?
I have no idea.
We are neck and neck.
It's really anybody's game
right now it's a toss-up.
Josh, Jesse, both
of you guys brought
in finale weapons that performed
incredibly well in our tests.
Only one of you can be the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
And that champion is Josh.
Congratulations.
You're the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Jesse, unfortunately your
blade didn't make the cut.
Jesse, you brought
us a fantastic weapon.
And this came down to
the finest of details.
Your weapon took
a bit more damage,
and your opponent's
weapon was a little bit
lighter and easier to control.
For those reasons,
we're letting you go.
All right.
Jesse, please,
surrender your weapon.
JESSE: Second place is--
it's not fun, but Josh
brought a better blade.
I give it my best, and I
put my best work out there.
I came here to prove to
myself that I'm not just
a backyard knife maker,
and I'm ecstatic that I
made it this far.
All right, Josh.
Congratulations.
You're the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
Yeah, it's amazing.
It's an amazing feeling.
Please present your
blade to the judges.
[laughing]
What?
Are you kidding?
Holy crap.
I'm the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
I'm-- I'm speechless.